usually when I pass bicyclists while I
Drive I'm going bike now after seeing
this movie it's more like sir I respect
you I respect you not gonna look at
bicyclists the same way Premium rush is
directed by David Koepp what's actually
supposed to come out originally in
January of this year I think a large
reason they pushed it back is because
people are like hey after Dark Knight
Rises comes out Joseph gordon-levitt is
gonna be bigger than he is now let's
release it then nevertheless they said
there was some kind of production
problem and they pushed the comeback now
I was never bad-mouthing this movie
because I love the star and I really
like the filmmaker David Koepp this
movies written and directed by him as
well and this guy has had a huge career
of writing really good movies he's had a
couple stinkers in there but let me give
you a recap of his career he wrote
Jurassic Park Carlito's Way Mission
Impossible the lost world wrote and
directed stir of echoes wrote spider-man
wrote and directed secret window wrote
War of the Worlds he wrote Indiana Jones
in the Kingdom of the Crystal Skull
excuse me alright let me out of the next
one he wrote and directed ghost town and
he wrote angels and demons yeah there's
a few stinkers in there but for the most
part that's the kind of movie you can
snap your fingers and I have a chick in
your bed in a couple minutes
good job David Koepp and so I was
excited for this movie because that's a
lot of talent in this movie Joseph
gordon-levitt and this writer and
director he's had such a prolific career
I was pumped for this movie and you know
what I had a lot of fun with this movie
it was a great time a really good rush
that makes sense it's about the secret
covert world of bike messengers and
Joseph gordon-levitt gets this package
he has to deliver and it turns out that
basically everyone in New York City once
had package for one reason or another it
seems that way anyway but mostly it's
just Michael Shannon who's a very very
determined cop a dirty cop and he's got
his own ideas about things and he means
that package for a very specific reason
not a good one when Gordon Levitt
discovers the true reason of why he has
to deliver this package then it becomes
sort of a moral issue and he decides to
do the right thing and try to do it and
I really like that about his character
his character isn't terribly fleshed out
there's not a lot of fleshing out of his
character but there's enough meat to the
backstory with him this
the girl this former relationship that's
kind of still brewing and you're like
what's going on with that and so it does
add something to his character it's not
complete non characterization it's just
there could have been a little bit more
Michael Shannon was really good in the
film he plays the villain he is after
this thing for a very selfish reason and
Joseph gordon-levitt understands why and
he's trying to protect it for him but
really the whole thing you get involved
with this movie is this whole world of
this bike messenger thing this covert op
bike messenger world where they all
protect each other they help each other
and I really like that it was just I've
never actually seen a movie like this
really can you actually think of a movie
in which bike messengers are the main
protagonists and they're trying to get
some kind of very hot object to somebody
I mean it's very original in that sense
so although the film is a little
formulaic and once you kind of get into
and realize what the actual reason
behind this object he has you know like
why everyone's after it it is kind of
corny it is kind of corny and cliched
but the fact that the movie itself was
so interesting and fun and just honestly
just fun a lot of fun one of the best
paced films I've seen all year it's
essentially one big chase scene for the
most part and because of that I had a
lot of fun the premium rush it does have
some characterization problems some of
the plot is very cheesy and it does tell
the story in a nonlinear sense and well
that worked at sometimes certain
flashbacks seemed completely unnecessary
but for the most part I had a lot of fun
with Premium Ross I thought Joseph
gordon-levitt's great in it I liked his
character I liked the film I liked the
action I thought it was directed very
well I'm gonna give premium rush a B+ so
if you guys seen the film yet if you did
what you think of it whatever your
opinion is let me know thanks for
watching guys and if you like this then
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes